at some point i will be able to code you
yannick you will be able to
code you to code me yes so that
finally you will release videos in time
[Music]
random guessing my classifier 47
accuracy nice yes
yes if you change the seed you can get
48.
haha you'll never reach me yes i will
how
by coming up with a better allergy
no but using a weaker baseline
getting published is so easy it's a job
yeah it's a job
yannick yeah do you do you sometimes i
realize that
you know my life every three months is
going to be like a
deadline is this real life this is it
it doesn't say it's just is this the
people this is it
like some some years ago i thought it
was gonna be fun you know
you just you know enjoy the life you
just you know
have nice conversations like you you you
try your best
you you think about things like for a
long time and then you find
no that does not sound like machine
learning research
okay two things we don't have long times
and thinking
model overfits on training data
new data i got one paper rejected
because their view was like
where is cypher that was the review
where is sci-fi where is it where is it
if there's no cipher how should i know
how does any
paper get accepted without cfar it's
called seafarer i don't know
maybe it's called cipher i don't know i
don't know it's like an abbreviation of
something
people who study latin will call it cfar
social decency guidelines
copy 19 1.5 meters
immediate outlet that's that's uh that's
very true
i'm having something like that to deal
with right now
i think i forgot something if you forgot
it wasn't that important
yeah you're right
this could actually work you know like
there are these
aren't there these proofs that some of
these algorithms only converge if you
like
average over gradients yeah so if you
accumulate your gradients
technically with a decreasing learning
rate this might work yeah and it gets
all wrong
so yeah that's exactly how it's done but
uh what's the story behind this
if i have a story there's no story no
i'll just give you a minute
i didn't get it uh should i really i
should really calculate yeah
it's true right it's true yeah it's
actually true
okay this is actually worth it but like
okay it's
saturday i woke up two hours ago
yeah it's actually true it's actually
true
beautiful beautiful douchiness
it's a word i didn't know epsilon is
expected
to grow very large over the next 48
hours
has to be small enough enough small
enough
abstract introduction results
did i tell you this maybe it was also in
the album review where it was paper
it's mine that's my paper
i remember was like in this paper in the
specific paper there was this um
okay uh we proved that this is true and
in the
introduction it was like sometimes
like the same the same thing but with
sometimes
we show that sometimes on under some
assumptions
even and when you read the paper it's
actually just an example
not everyone should code recommended for
you
i'm surprised that sometimes i i look at
the fingers
i don't i will never enjoy it and then i
do
and then i do us youtubers we have to
regularly sacrifice
gpus to the algorithm and the
recommendation yeah
it really likes gpus does it do you have
to burn them do you have to make them
burn you like you have to take like some
cooler liquid and
sprinkle it on top and if you dance
around it and some flowers on top of it
and then you have to eat it
omg i love all this watercooled
cpus
new toothpaste exists dentist
i did i bet i didn't get the machine
learning thing is this a snow machine
okay okay yeah perfect perfect i love
this
i don't know why but it's so good
yannick that's the big surprise at the
end of this video there's gonna be a big
surprise what is it's a citation
from the office okay but yeah seriously
for each one of you
yannick is gonna make a gift is it a
matlab license
damn it don't spoil forms of birth
control tensorflow i should just put my
machine learning when your model
improves from five percent accuracy to
seven percent accuracy machine learning
she's learning finding global minima
she's learning finding local minima yeah
and that's
so damn true theory people are
theory people are the worst weird weird
that's even true like but
i i'm completely serious 100 serious
like they get excited about infinitely
wide
neural networks oh yeah or or what if
you take the step size to be
infinitely small yeah you that's that's
how you do things
i mean the only thing that's infinitely
wide is your mom
self-driving cars aren't even hard to
make all just programming not to hit
stuff
[Laughter]
don't you know in all of my codes true
story in all of my code
i write in a line and it's usually like
a comment
to doubt but but i write in a line that
says
if target equals yannick then
don't fire really just i anticipate that
some of my code will be used in
in the robot overlord army yeah yeah
that's such a smart move i know it's
such a smart move you gotta think ahead
for some reason they will shoot
everything except the traffic lights
how
[Laughter]
interviewer what's your biggest strength
i'm an expert
in machine learning now good that we did
this this way because the other way
would have been a bit strange
okay what's nine plus ten
it's three nothing close it's 19
it's 16. wrong it's still 19.
it's 18. no it's 19. it's 19.
you're higher yes i wonder what gpd3
would say to this
what should we try it out we should try
it out
when you drop the learning rate
everyone is so everyone's like freaking
out
what happened here but they dropped the
learning rate it's so clear
it's like that's what you do you you
stagnate
you divide it by ten sugar boom i'll
give you 10 seconds
to copy what's on the whiteboard the
whiteboard
it's actually from my video yeah i i i
kind of remember something similar to
that
what was this i have no idea not a
slightest clue
so this actually is also on my video
first they really tried they really
tried but
sometimes i'm mean if i make a mistake
on a video
or something i'll put like a comment
ah you never make mistakes before before
i set the video
to visible it's just so mean to the
people who want to do this
mom if your friends jumped off a bridge
would you jump
between her
[Laughter]
how much time i i needed this meme and i
didn't know i needed that that's um
no you can't just add more parameters
and data to model gvt3 is no different
from elisa since it's just glorified
pattern matching and curvating not true
intelligence which requires a symbolic
representation of the input which
connectionist models will never be able
to do also the data needed is almost an
entire percentage of the total possible
data we could collect
and the hardware needed to trend d3 is
do you think jpt
is intelligent i think he's aware
and he oh my god no oh no
oh oh no oh we're gonna leave this in
i'll crush us do you think gpd3 is
intelligent though
i think well i think i like the color so
i like the colors of the gpu there
anybody with best colors it's like
slightly you know funny so it can be
funny
you know but not intelligent do you do
you feel do you think
i think it is
not is
i think it is it is
i'll be canceled for like the 50th time
researchers hate him local man discovers
one weird trick general intelligence
turns out
you just weren't using enough layers
learn the secret sweet stunning result
learn the truth now
yep yes but uh that's that's again
me that's again me own it
without the stickers this sticker they
own it own it
and that is probably the island paper do
you know the adam
proof is famously wrong right i very
much know
oh yeah yeah i do i just heard it i just
repeat it to sound smart no i i
i know it i know it it's like there are
at least four mistakes in my proof
and i think that it got probably like 30
000 citations before
before realizing that it was uh we're
still getting citations now
now you know the second part of the
story well now it's 60 000.
the other paper the paper fixes the
mistake introduces a
ams grad the proof the mistake is
basically the v
variable
then it's a problem for the proof okay
and
ams grad fixes the mistake but now
there's another paper
that tells that actually adam does
converge
so if we go back to the faction no no
guys nice i just did it wrong
you just did it wrong but yeah yeah it's
like when you don't use the method your
teacher wants you to use
exactly yeah but but uh but nobody used
the ams grad
yeah nobody ever used it no no i spit on
ams
i really don't like it albert einstein
insanity is doing the same thing
over and over again and expecting
different results
[Music]
that's how i make papers come on seed
equals two
or maybe like resubmission
how it started yeah
against the mob this is a very dark
period how it's going
in the channels versus twitter
yeah yeah we have a superstar right here
superstar
we don't we don't talk about this too no
no we don't talk about this
that's nothing happened nothing happened
nvidia new ai be like
that's what they do then you might how
many millions of
dollars are going into just making your
eyes go
crazy
[Laughter]
you forgot
all right that was it for ring review
thank you so much for watching
thank you thank you thank you i want to
thank yannick for having me here
it is always a pleasure yeah and
hopefully
2021 will have also cake yannick
where the hell is the cake more cake
yeah
bye bye
[Music]
you